what can do this video I'm playing GM
mouths at all and this is what you get
playing on the internet against people
that I already have that form for how
many years ma what's it do click 37
years 1976 if i'm not mistaken and he's
playing the king's indian in even in
1976 then you the king's indian display
the samish it's got a turkish flag does
it have a name in there nope but to six
and five minutes and is pretty a pretty
strong ok let's see you it's playing c6
young and there are probably a 6 i'm
playing a c5 p.m. just before he's
coming with b5 ok this is some uncommon
not quite sure what the ideas
she wants to take here under 95 anything
like that
hmm
sorry I'm not quite sure I'm sorry maybe
95 but I don't really see the point
and I don't understand what he's doing
to be honest yes but I thought I just
play 94 and I'm fine am I not or
somewhere else actually it's a that's
actually debatable where'd you go even
taking is not completely completely
crazy yeah why not actually just take it
and we're now interesting night be 385
can be a good which is got the queenside
weekend black needs to learn to get some
active peace play otherwise is just in
very bad shape this is a position that I
would love to have against a very strong
player in the tournament game with
enough time and trying to diminish any
chances I back to the team okay yeah I
need to take so he's attacking on c3
King into this Bishop c4 this is bad can
I can play wicked d1 down not oops oops
the the bishop is saying oops okay yeah
okay this took me a while i don't really
think he can take on c3 it's not not on
okay let's get rid of this book just
annoying okay you don't never know it
right f5 to be some I cannot really take
it
yeah I thought I'd taken a chickpea some
know maybe you can play rupee a dome
yeah this is possible
yeah spend too much time here as usual
thought night c4 actually this move I
don't understand at all ok I'd spectacle
yes also as usual if I don't understand
the movements usually a tactical a climb
off ok I've got 94 I Scott night sea
foam okay okay and then just takes only
three yeah I've just blundered the PCM
ok I am just playing too slowly that
this was very tricky in this game black
was risking quite a lot here on the
queenside his is just positionally
busted but he's got lots of activity and
that maybe this just is more porn yeah
yeah but I was just missing things all
the time yeah is probably just too
active him
if I get some control over this position
and diminishes activity then then whitis
is just in great shape I cut the better
King I've got the spawn fixed but he's
got the activity the computer suggestion
is actually quite good but I didn't
consider this move at all I played the
move sorry but this is the problem I
should take with the night yeah it
hadn't seen a NC 93 yeah this should at
least them 94 we should at least be a be
okay for white yeah I never were see a
play within next to King around III
cannot take him because of 95 or 98
whatever I get the point you had tricky
very tricky game maybe around here i can
i can improve yeah then the most natural
move is 94 maybe i should have just
played 94 i play with all the pieces on
the board but it was tempting to get the
queens off the end game is usually
excellent in this kind of structure 94
is just a good news though let's say
something like that yeah this is just
bad for like her
it's a I know it's the Kings Indian and
so on but what what is this just just
full of weaknesses this position the
comp is already giving white more than
one pound advantage yeah but should be
two and their phone was also the problem
black suffers on none on the queenside
end in the center this is even better
nift ft 7 s I saw is really a strange
idea and I he played I played well after
that yeah I didn't have any precision in
this game okay thanks for watching